in scotland's former first minister alex
salmond has re-entered frontline
politics this afternoon
announcing that he's to become the
leader of the new pro-independence alba
party
the party will stand candidates in the
scottish parliamentary elections on the
6th of may
boris johnson has already said no to the
snp proposals
he will find it much more difficult to
say no to a parliament and a country
and the independence debate will be
recast not as the
tories against the snp but boris johnson
against scotland's parliament
representing scotland's people
today alba are hoisting a flag in the
wind
planting our saltire in a hill in the
next few weeks
we'll see how many will rally to our
standard
well let's speak now to sky scotland
correspondent james matthews who joins
us from
edinburgh interesting james to see what
the implications will be for alex
salmon's former protege nicola sturgeon
and whether or not she
feels the pressure to harden her
pro-independence line
yeah nicholas told you not happy
certainly in the words of a statement
from the snp
alex salmon talking about planting a
flag in the wind
their view would be rather that he's
spitting
in the wind let me read you some of what
they have had to say
they say at this time of crisis the
interests of the country must come first
and should not be obscured by the
self-interest
of someone who shows no sign whatsoever
of reflecting
on serious concerns about his own
conduct
that's the view of the snp on the launch
of this alba party alba the galact ward
for scotland alex almond is its leader
as you say isabel
uh he and colleagues will be standing at
this forthcoming
hollywood election the way he said they
were going to play it
was not try and eat into the
the constituency vote they're not
standing in that element of this vote
but they are standing in the list vote
uh
basically that will create the potential
for them eating into the votes of other
pro-independence
parties that certainly would have to be
the main concern i think
of the independent minded among
the electorate i took the opportunity to
ask alex salmond
about that to put it to him that as a
man who took scotland to the brink
of independence in india ref 2014
is he now in danger of being the man who
pulls scotland back from the brink
this is what he had to say so after the
two court cases the jury the three
inquiries
it is time to move on uh i wanted to
talk about the future of scotland for
the last three years now i've got the
opportunity thanks to the alba party
and that's exactly what i intend to do
and tend to do it an entirely positive
way
we've got to establish the independence
platform
which will enable us to take this
country to independence
there you go alex salmon talking about a
super majority he was also talking about
their
uh this business of the last two years
he's a man who was acquitted
at a criminal trial of sexual assault
but there were many details
that were heard publicly about his
behavior concerns about inappropriate
behavior
bullying during his term in office and
he made the point very strongly
and repeatedly when he was asked in that
zoom briefing
that he's been subject to two judges
and a jury and a number of inquiries and
he has been cleared by them and is
looking to move on in terms of where he
takes the politics what he says is that
he
is aiming for hashtag super majority
that's all over the launch press release
he
is saying that the strategy is not to
not to fight the snp but to complement
the snp
to aim for a parliament that has a
broad church of independence minded msps
and place the hollywood parliament in a
place where
boris johnson finds it more difficult to
resist indirect too
rather than just taking on and opposing
the snp
alex salmon says he'll be looking at a
parliament that is pro-independence
and that would create a different
political
dynamic his opponents nicholas sturgeon
among them would beg to differ
about the interests of the political
imperative that is
uh independence she doesn't see it and
sn the smp party
doesn't see this intervention as helpful
well either way it's gonna be a lively
six weeks until the elections james
thanks very much
indeed now the prime minister has backed
his conservative colleagues following
sanctions by chai